donde están tom phillips y bruno pereyra
en brasilia un grupo de manifestantes
exige justicia y respuestas por la
desaparición del periodista británico
thomas phillips y el experto indigenista
brasileño bruno pereyra
es el nutriente es uno de los nuestros
los que desapareció estaba amenazado no
sabemos lo que pudo pasar pero esperamos
lo mejor
miembros de la fundación nacional del
indio funai convocaron a una
movilización después de las
declaraciones de su propio presidente
quien dijo que la pareja no tenía
permiso para ingresar al valle de javarí
y lo acusaron de no garantizar la
seguridad de los trabajadores
necesitamos un cambio lo que está
pasando en funai es decir el
desmantelamiento la desprotección de las
tierras indígenas el fomento de la
violencia en las áreas indígenas
el rastro se perdió hace más de una
semana a lo largo de un tramo remoto del
río y ta kwai en el extremo occidental
de brasil cerca de la frontera con
colombia y perú
en la zona miembros del grupo indígena
uruguaya y oficiales de la policía
seguían buscando en su último reporte
dijeron que las tareas se acercaban a su
final después de que descubrieran
pertenencias de los hombres cerca del
último sitio donde fueron vistos lo que
concentró las tareas en un perímetro
menor entretanto la policía federal
brasileña dijo que esperaba concluir
esta semana el análisis forense de una
de las muestras de sangre recolectadas
en la embarcación de un hombre
sospechoso de estar involucrado
previamente se había informado del
hallazgo de dos cadáveres
pereira viajaba en una investigación con
philips un reportero independiente que
ha escrito para the gardian y el
'washington post' y estaba trabajando en
un libro sobre la amazonía se
encontraban en una remota zona selvática
que alberga la mayor cantidad de
indígenas no contactados del mundo y un
lugar de paso de bandas traficantes
ilegales